Right. All right,
good evening. Glad you're here.
We're gonna go ahead and get started. We are in week
11 of a 12-week course and so we'll be
wrapping things up in the next couple of nights next
this one this Wednesday and next Wednesday and
then we'll shut down for the holidays. I'm not quite
sure what it's gonna look like in the spring yet. But this
won't be the last time we do this course it might
be the last time we do it in 12 weeks and we
may be able to do it in a shorter amount of time. But but this
was a good good first start a proud of you guys for being
here everyone of you. I've got some exciting
news for you. But before we do it, let's kind of review. This
is the pathway and who would
like to get up here and talk about the pathway. I'm
not gonna make you do that. So what's your
job at each step in this pathway? Well at
worship Services if you meet somebody who
doesn't have
CG will you invite them say I'll help
you find one come with me out to the information desk because we're
trying to work people in this direction and CG
is where they get involved relationally. Did you
know this is such great news that the
Sunday night CG's and some of the 11. I'm in
the 1030 CG's they'll meet for
their Bible study discussion, but then they'll break
up into micro groups afterwards because they have more time
and so they they do the whole
thing in the in the context of their CG and what
we're learning is is this is the sweet spot right here. This is
where we can do identify that relational
environment with an intentional leader
and a relational environment and a reproducible process. And
what we have is a disciple making movement in
our hands and what is a disciple one who's
following Jesus being changed by Jesus and is committed
to the mission of Jesus and that's disciple making
so I want you to have these memorized and
Part of your who you are again. We've we've done
this before. I'm trying to see if the Yahoo mocks. My
handwriting is here because I may have her come up here and write this
down. Okay, I see you back there. But so one
of the one of the great things
about the large group time, the worship service is that
it's very well-timed. It's very precise. Our
speaker has a PHD in discipleship. Well,
it might be more of a demon. I'm not 100% sure.
But anyway, so the music is playing and rehearsed
everything looks great and you can literally come
anonymously sit in the dark and not
have to speak to anybody.
now
that's the strength if you don't have anything to say, but that's not how
disciples are made. So what we've discovered is that
as we climb this opportunity for a more
opportunity than we can find genuine intimacy.
That means we know and are known.
As intimacy I was somebody say I can't ride intimacy and
why we do that we do that through transparency. We're going
to be talking about that.
transparency and somebody want to give me a
Now, I'm just kidding. I'm not mad. I
can Spell transparency but
not while I'm talking at the same time.
So who let's let's do this. Give me one or
two Word answers. What is the definition of transparency anyone?
openness
authentic
vulnerable
So yeah, do you see that? That was like a snowball did
you see what was happening there? What we're trying to do ultimately is
have and go real slow. Stop talking for
a second account.
A Billet team. Okay. Thank
you very much. So we really
want accountability because it is in the The
Crucible of accountability where we've been
honest enough to say this is a weakness that I
struggle with or this is a sin that I am tempted
with it is within that Crucible then now we
are
we're risking trusting one another with this
transparent trust to hold me
accountable. See how's that fight going and with
some accountability you're gonna discover that the holy
spirit is able to to help you stand stronger
than you would alone. All right.
So let's talk about the Holy Spirit know the holy spirit's role.
The Holy Spirit has a number. We're
not going to be able to cover the Holy Spirit tonight in five minutes,
but the Holy Spirit does so much we've talked
about how the holy spirit is a teacher. So I'm gonna take
that off your plate. You don't have to be a teacher to be a disciple
maker. All you need to do is understand the holy spirit that
he draws people. What does he do?
here
he gives New Life In Christ. He the
Holy Spirit also draws us into a relationship with Christ and
the Holy Spirit also lives in every follower
of Jesus. So when a disciple group
meets together when a micro group meets together the holy spirit.
Is there among them.
And he guides us into truth. He
keeps us in Fellowship. He convicts us
of sin. And he leads us in guides Us in the direction
that we ought to go. What is our role and that's not
as important as the holy spirit's role but in
the Providence of God, he has given us the
opportunity an honor and privilege of
Keeping in step with the spirit or walking with
the spirit. So there's really only one thing we have to do. My role
is to live under the control of the
Holy Spirit. Hopefully you've read Galatians 5:16 says
but I say walk by the
spirit and you'll not gratify the desires of
the flesh. So let's talk really quickly about the
Holy Spirit. The Holy Spirit has been commissioned by
God to to be
The Power Within every individual
believer. What did the disciples say?
And then what did Jesus say did Jesus is I'm going
to prepare a place for you. And this is if I go, I
will send a paraclete. That's the Greek word
for comfort her or Advocate and
he will dwell within you and you'll do
greater things that I've ever done and the paraclete
the actual interpretation of
that Greek word paraclete is one who comes alongside.
And isn't it great to think that God himself in
the presence of the holy spirit will come alongside us as
we are working at being disciples and making disciples
and empowering us and equipping us
and motivating us. And so I feel as
if I can okay. We've been together 11 weeks and
so we're really close now, aren't we?
Yeah, thank you. One of you.
I think that if we've discovered that this is
the commission of God to make disciples and if we
have been committed enough to meet together not just under
instruction, but also in micro group.
Test pilots test tubes if you will, we've actually
experienced what it means to be in a micro group. And now
in the next two weeks is
I'm going to be giving you the total
responsibility of deciding. Okay.
I'm either going to be in a micro group or I'm gonna lead a
micro group.
And it's going to be on you and you know, what you're going to do you're gonna have to decide is
the holy spirit going to lead me to do
this or am I going to decide that's not
for me.
And you can do that. But but here's here's something about
the holy spirit that makes him unique. Okay, the holy spirit
is promised to indwell and to fill
where I'm from in Tulsa filled with
the holy spirit means something different. All right. I'm not
talking about some sort of ecstatic experience or some
sort of a
I don't know emotional issue. But when I talk about
being filled with the spirit, I'm talking about the Holy Spirit and dwelling
me to a place where I sense is presence and
his power. That's the kingdom of God for me is
the presence and power of God through the presence of the Holy Spirit
his Reign his rule his will
his way are all outside my grasp
but through his presence and power and the Holy
Spirit. Now, I have the opportunity to participate in his
will and his way and his Rule and
his Reign and that's what makes the Christian life.
So meaningful. Okay, I'm
gonna just tell you that in the presence and
power of the Holy Spirit when I'm filled with the spirit and
walking in the spirit as the scripture challenges me to
do so, I can't imagine doing anything any else
any other way.
However, the Holy Spirit can also be grieved.
scripture talks about how
with our repeated Disobedience that we
can grieve the Holy Spirit and then pretend
to live the Christian Life in his power without his
power.
I'm not going to do this by rays of hands. Okay, and
so, please don't raise your hand right. Now. How many
of you have done that and sometimes the Christian Life can be
actually quite
quite difficult in your own power
And so what happens is you'll step away because it is difficult
and it feels good because now you've grieved the
holy spirit in the further that you can get away from him. Then the more
you feel like I don't have to feel that conviction of
the Holy Spirit. What I would suggest to you is instead
of grieving the Holy Spirit. Then you the gospel
response is to repent of the
decision of the of the things that you've done selfish things disobedient
things evil fleshly things.
You're you repent of those things and then
you you ask for forgiveness and then by
faith you step back into the presence of the
power of the Holy Spirit and You Begin since his
filling in his leading in his guiding
I can take you back to the
Frontage Road in Frisco, Oklahoma where the
Holy Spirit just
just kind of came out of my
chest right after just a disciple moment.
I I could not believe this is gonna
happen to you and I
want you to be able to tell me this story. All right,
when it happens to you. I want you to be able to articulate how
and why it happened, but you don't
plan it.
You don't structure it. There's
no three steps to it, but there will
be a moment where the holy spirit makes himself evident in
the process of transformation. And when you see a
person go from either death to life or from
Infant Christianity to young adult
Christianity and all sudden. It's not about him so
much. It's about God God's plan for him
or her and you just see I
mean, hopefully you're gonna
have an opportunity to answer that question tonight. Have you ever been
influenced by the Holy Spirit? If you ever experience
the power of the Holy Spirit Well, I was
like I said, I was in this IHOP. I was with my micro group a
guy the Holy
Spirit was just all over him and he was
Deeply convicted by about some of the decisions and behaviors
that he'd made and he says I want you guys to pray for me because
you know, everybody in the
room knows what the answer is you need to repent you need to you know,
get your life right and you get back and step with the spirit everybody with the
answer was but at that moment when one disciple
turned to the other I didn't have anything to say about it and
he said and it was like the spirit was speaking through him. I want
you to know I've been praying for you every day since I heard this was a struggle
for you.
And I mean it was just like guys I
want to know I'm in a Southern Baptist nine months before I was
born. Okay, when I raised my hands I raised him about this
high and I feel pretty uncomfortable about it actually so I am not, you
know flaming charismatic, but I'm
just telling you it was as if the Shekinah Glory of
God fell on that I hop at that moment and we
were just like in holy
Ah of what God was doing and I
want that experience for you. I want
you to begin to experience the transformative power of the
holy spirit in your micro group so that you can say to yourself. I can't
imagine doing anything else with my life for the
rest of my life.
I think that micro group disciple making
is not just transformational. I believe it's generational.
I believe that well, I heard a story this week that
I can't tell because I don't have permission to but it had
happened in this room.
Or a micro group did something that was profoundly transformative
and and
I heard it in appraiser report and the
staff meeting.
And I was just thinking to myself that's exactly what we're wanting
to see happen. So anyway, my role
is just to live under the control of the Holy Spirit
Breath by breath Moment by moment word by
word day by day of week by week and know the goal.
The goal is transformation. Here's three necessary
ingredients. These are the things that need
to happen in your micro group. And in order for you to get
to have transformation and one is this transparent trust
as we were discussing.
You have to have transparent trust
and here's three things that will help you get there by affirming one
another through encouragement.
Man, I'm glad you're here. I was thought I was going to be here breakfast by
myself. I'm so glad you're here.
And hey, would you lead our prayer next week? And you know,
and I knew I could count on you. But but again
encouragement is is a powerful motivator and
we all need it also by walking with
one another through difficult circumstances. If your
micro group is together for at least a year. I can guarantee you at least
everybody in that room in that group is going to go
through a difficult circumstance.
Could be a health issue. It could be a family issue relational issue
could be a financial issue. I don't know but it's going
to be difficult. And if you walk with one another through those difficult circumstances
that transparent trust will continue to
build I have lots of stories to tell you about that, but we
need to move on and here's probably the most difficult one.
And as an intentional leader, you're going to have to lead out in this. Okay, and
that's the admission of sins and weaknesses. Okay, Bible
says if we confess our
sins one to another then we
will be healed and I'm not saying that you need to do that
in a CG. All right guys, I haven't been
here in a few weeks, but I've got some sins I need to you know see Geezer
for one thing. But when you're with a micro group of people
that you know, you can trust you say I need you guys to hold me
accountable something I really struggle with this.
And when you that's that vulnerability that's that
transparency and if you can admit that I
struggle with this and I need your accountability with this you're going to
be surprised through their prayer and through a mutuality of hey,
we're in this together. Nobody's perfect. And
we're going to help each other. Then you're gonna begin to see this transparent
trust and that is again a necessary
ingredient for a transformation number true. The
truth of God's word.
Okay, holy spirit is
a teacher God's word is God in in his
specific Revelation and we
have second Timothy 3:16 and 17 all scriptures
given by inspiration of God as profitable for correction reproof.
I mean instruction correction reproof
and instruction and righteousness at the man of God, maybe perfect and
thoroughly furnished and all good works. That's the KJV version.
Sorry. I'll get back to the ESV. So what
can God do it's profitable
for teaching the holy spirit is the teacher for
reproof. You're going to be a learning and identifying things
that need to change about your life and about the lives of
those in your group. And what you need to do is instead of
what you have been doing and then training in righteousness.
And why so that we can be complete and equipped for
every good work? So again, not just
that transparent trust, but the truth of
God's word though. That's the one two punch.
And then lastly a mutual accountability. This is
not the leader holding the members
accountable. This is mutual accountability.
And this is
perhaps as an intention leader one
of your greatest.
strengths
Is to say hey guys, let's let's pray for
one another. I want to find out how can we pray for one another? Let
me tell you how you can pray for me.
Okay instead of saying how can we
pray for one another?
And then just waiting you model that
behavior how let me tell you how you can pray for me.
And what I would probably say
is you guys know my mom's 87 she's got dementia. She's
probably gonna call here in a minute. It's gonna pop up right here in the whole group's gonna
see it.
But she'll call me last night. She called
me nine times.
And doesn't remember that she's called me.
And and I'm not asking you for prayer for her because that's that's
what God has given to her. I'm gonna ask
you to pray for me so that I'll I'll respond in Grace.
You know.
And so what did I just do I just shared a real
difficult circumstance.
And and I was honest and transparent enough to say sometimes
I don't even want to answer the phone.
You know sometimes when I answer the phone, I'm not always present.
You know and so when as a as an intention leader, I'll
model that kind of mutual accountability
says anybody else struggling with something then
they're going to be more inclined to say. Yeah. I got a struggle here,
too.
And so you see these are the things that the necessary ingredients is
transparent trust. The truth of God's word and
mutable Mutual accountability. Now, here's
some exciting news and I need everybody here
to understand what I'm about to tell you. Okay, we have
just launched today another page on
the Henderson Hills Baptist Church website. If you go
to hhbc.com forward slash disciple.
Then it will pull up three buttons and one
is as I want to be discipled. Another button
is I want to make disciples and another button is
Micro group updates now. I don't
know if this is going to work. Okay. So you guys forgive me
if it doesn't laugh at me if you want to but up
look at here, okay.
Let's see if I can go back and what that'll do.
Okay, there it is. Right there. There's your it's gonna
get better it launched today. It'll have a description of what discipleship is
but there's your three buttons. I want
to be discipled. I want to make disciples and micro
group Updates. This is gonna
be an opportunity from this point until God calls me
home or he returns to take us all this
is going to be where we meet together as a disciple
making movement and on micro group
update you just click it and it'll take it to a form
on our church website. Of course, you'll feel
that out.
And if you're in the system, it'll populate itself
doesn't look like I'm in the system. I don't know how that might
work. But
let me see HH. No, that's not it. What is my
email? I say, oh he
at hhbc.com
and it's gonna make me do my football mobile phone 918
And no one text me because that'll come up on my iPad. Okay?
If everybody does it won't that be hilarious?
Not much actually.
That's not it.
Let's just keep going to a four six seven
zero zero.
Oh, please don't make me put the whole thing in all right.
So let's look at this.
Are you a micro group leader or participant?
Right. Now I know that we'll have some who want to lead and some who just want to
participate. All right, what are the names of the members of
your current macro group and you can type those in there? Okay at
this is just
For this group. All right is your
current micro group going to continue to meet I did
not ask you to do that. But some of you have decided
against my better judgment now,
I'm just kidding. I really don't care if if you want to
continue to meet I think that's fine.
But I would love to know it. Okay, so you'll click yes or no,
whether we're going to continue to meet what time and day you're gonna
meet and then the look of these last two and these are gonna be my favorites. Okay
story briefly explain how
God is at work transforming lives in your micro group. These stories
are being collected industry to encourage one
another and Inspire new disciple makers.
When God does something like what we just described a
transformative Transcendent experience where
the power and the presence the Holy Spirit was palpable tell me
about it.
And then we'll share that with one another in ways. Discreetly
if you ask but in ways to see that listen
disciple making changes lives and changing lives
as the goal when transformation occurs in
the glory of God is is applauded in
renowned and and people want to get involved in that right and
then this last one notes briefly explain
how this option community staff can assist you and encourage
you to stop a maker and any question is not out
of balance. If you have a question, he's like does anybody
pay attention to these notes? You know, I don't care what the question
is.
but but that will get to me and I will personally
call you and help you through whatever you're
needing to know about disciple making all right,
and then you submit that and it's not going to
let you tell you put all your
Red red line see that there. You got to
put all that in. So anyway, but here's the
deal.
I would love for you to do this without me baking you.
Okay, but I will beg you.
All right, and so imagine if
you will.
An avalanche of emails coming on a weekly basis.
It's possible. You don't want that.
I'm just kidding. I'm not gonna do that. But anyway, I really this is this is
gonna help so much because I think
the intentional leader is responsible for collecting the persons
in this micro group, but there will be people happen to
me Sunday morning a guy comes up to me because man, I want to be discipled where
I go.
And and I so I had to write his name down, you know
like it was 1974 and anyway, and
then I had to remember where I put it and that kind of thing. This is gonna help us.
All right. So if you have
any questions about that ask me a privately later, but I want us
to pray together and I want us to get into our micro groups. One of
the questions is how did the Holy Spirit impact you or influence
you I hope that you are able to share stories about
God's involvement in your life, and maybe
it's recently maybe it was when you were younger, but there's there's
nothing more powerful than
when we share legitimately.
Transcendent transforming stories of how God's
power has made us into his likeness and it's why I
do what I do and that's why I do it until Till the
End Amen. Let's pray.
Father thank you for these people for their
willingness to come Lord. I Thank you that.
That you have promised that if we
ask anything according to your will you hear us? And so we
know father that it is your will that we become life-changing
disciple makers we're
transformation occurs. And your glory is Renown and so
Lord. That's our prayer. And if it starts tonight, we
would pray that that we would recognize
that that's exactly what's happening because we prayed and you're
answering our prayers Lord in these coming weeks. We'll
have to make decisions as far as when we're gonna
meet and where we're going to meet and who is going to be in our group and I pray Lord
that the spirit of God will not let us rest until
we have come to terms of the fact that you have called us
to be disciple makers.
And this is because Jesus did what he did for us and it is
in his name. We pray. Amen. Amen. Let's meet
together.